the 2020 presidential campaign is
already well underway on the Democratic
side there are dozens of candidates in
the race and possibly dozens more to
come on the Republican side there's just
the incumbent president everyone assumes
he wants to be reelected
most presidents do but what if Donald
Trump had decided he's had enough too
many investigations too much nastiness
too few upsides it wouldn't be a crazy
conclusion I'd like to spend your 70s
locked in the White House so let's say
Trump had decided he wants to lose in
2020 and get back to his old life how
would he do that
let's see he might start by proposing
more than half a billion dollars in
Medicare cuts that's something that
nobody outside the libertarian symposia
circuit really wants to see so you do
that then he'd slash funding for the
e-verify program that would allow
companies to keep hiring illegal alien
labor in violation of a key campaign
promise after that he'd announcer
bringing in even more low-skilled
workers that would push down the wages
of the people who voted for him the most
vulnerable group in the country finally
he'd release a bunch of drug dealers
back onto the streets right in the
middle of the worst drug epidemic in
history and he continued our pointless
military intervention in Syria which in
no way benefits the United States if the
President did all that the message would
be very clear he has no idea what he ran
on in 2016
he just wants out well let's say voters
still didn't get the message maybe they
were too distracted by the Russia hoax
to notice at that point you'd have to do
something really extreme to get their
attention something so mindless and
counterproductive that there's literally
no way you could get reelected after
doing it you'd raise gas taxes and in
fact the administration is proposing
just that according to news reports the
White House is negotiating with
Democrats to height gap taxes on
gasoline in order to fund quote
infrastructure this is one of those
ideas that everyone in Washington loves
it cost them nothing they're too rich to
care what gas costs and by the way they
don't drive but if you live outside the
coastal cities and you're not rich
higher gas prices are a disaster they
hurt you immediately that's always true
anything that raises the price of gas
whether it's the green New Deal or some
new tax scheme promoted by a fake
conservative think-tank crushes the
weakest in our society
normal people hate it many of those
people voted for Donald Trump the first
time it's nuts and it's not like there
aren't other smarter less regressive
options if you want to raise money there
are many of them we could roll back some
of those 2017 tax cuts which went
overwhelmingly to higher earners and big
companies we could tax the billions in
remittances flowing from the United
States to the rest of the world remember
that idea we could tax carried interest
like the income it so obviously is we
should do that anyway just on principle
we could even tax capital gains like we
tax salaries Mitt Romney might finally
pay the same rate as your dentist and
that would be satisfying and then we
could get creative how about an 80% tax
on all lobbying produced by former
members of Congress that's a good one
how about an iPhone tax or how about a
tough new tax on a trillion-dollar
seattle-based Internet Retailer whose
entire business model depends on using
public roads to deliver their packages
companies like that have put an awful
lot of American businesses out of work
they clog our roads why aren't they
paying for infrastructure we could go on
plenty of obvious ideas out there hiking
taxes on working-class rural people is
not on the list unless you secretly want
to retire early in that case if you're
really sick of the job go with the gas
tax